moi j'ai aucun problème avec la gamme
comme je lui ai dit voilà moi je n'y a
aucun souci à agathe tu veux pas
redonner à cette [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
et retisse pardon pardon et l éruption
mais bien comme ça ça veut dire qu'il
aime glisser vraie
agression beaucoup de second degré dieu
voilà alors qu'ils avaient désamorcé
gentiment exactement voilà donc c'est
j'avais même pas que j'étais là puisque
jean lavallée j'étais à l'ouest ça va
vous au niveau de la mémoire si donc
vous reconnaissez
ouais michel drucker et
non mais vous n'avez rien contre jean
marie mai tout
savoir des différents exactement alors
pas bien parce que dans l'eau là ça lui
avait fait énormément mal m'avait écrit
non mais moi ça va il ya des repas je
vous aime beaucoup et tout je vous
trouve charmante la dernière fois
c'était des compliments toutes les deux
donc voilà ça m'ennuie parce que ce
qu'on ferait pas pour
vraiment ces listes étaient sept
héritiers un acte de paix le match est
en guerre avec personne non mais je
compare mes vins traité d' hystérique
quand même ça c'est non j'ai dit bigard
lalanne et les autistes eric abadie
bigard est un hystérique hystérique 1
au boston et dallas il suit pas la halle
alors on était bien parti
mais parce que fils enrique c'est un peu
ça c'est péjoratif
ensuite plutôt si à ce moment là alors
c'est pas plus et ce alors non il a dit
que tous
ses péchés bien sûr mais c'est il faut
remettre les choses dans leur contexte
et là après lui c'est donneraient
n'importe quoi pour un bonbon et pour
faire rire alors je comprends que ça
vous est blessé d'ailleurs j'étais la
première à dire excuse toi la mapad vrai
à l'époque donc je vais pas faire celle
qui osera voler ses vingt ans après
voilà après c'est vrai que c'est l'école
un peu al habachi tout ça où oui voilà
parfois au détriment de
voilà ils peuvent excéder gens non moi
ça m'avait pas le bon profil l'humour
mais c'est vrai que c'est
un sketch le plus célèbre c'était le
lâcher de [ __ ] quand même oui mais
c'est pas pareil que moi j'ai pas un
sketch il lâché deux chroniqueurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
au
dessus du nord
évidemment je n'ai rien contre vous
voilà entre jean marie vadrot
barça on l'a déjà dit vous avez tout à
fait le droit de mettre d'accord avec
lui après c'est vrai que l'art dont six
dans son contexte c'est vrai que c'est
vulgaire et que voilà il a vraiment ça
pour faire rire voilà mais je pense que
là comme je vous l'avais dit ce jour là
vous avez du second degré je pense que
vous êtes intelligente et que vous savez
que c'est ma copie venez vous voir enfin
sur le put quoi aucun train de vous
remettre les choses dans leur contexte
mais moi par exemple ma première télé
j'étais pétrifiée c'était michel drucker
on venait pour une pièce de théâtre et
bachy est là avec jean-marie chaud au
milieu des 2 et drucker dit alors
comment vous vous êtes rencontrés tous
les deux et je n'aime pas le temps
d'ouvrir la bouche que bassidi dans un
bar à [ __ ] et voilà et je sais que
c'est le rhume enfin j'ai été élevé
guillaume genton et j'ai vraiment
[Rires]
mais tout ça pour finir que c'est cette
école a pas d'animosité
et voyez c'est mon meilleur ami baffie
et franchement je me suis fait traiter
de [ __ ] pas mal de fois par les
émissions n'a pas envie de l'homme
c'est pour vous dire que c'est leur
humour grivois certes bien comme ça que
ça fonctionne